black threatens checkmate in one rook  takes knight will be checkmate  if and whoa okay crazy tactics prague is  just showing off now with some nice  geometry and i think we're about to see  a result because king takes rook now  it's a check king takes rook would walk  into a night fork white's knight will  plant itself in the center checking the  black king and winning the black queen  this this is just one of the most  beautiful games i've ever seen let alone  on the tour it's just a masterpiece  it's just fireworks non-stop every move  is a really crazy unexpected blow it's a  lesson in calculation right and tactical  motifs i mean that rook check and the  rook takes pawn sacrificing material and  all to get this this particular night  fork and uh we are definitely gonna see  it and i think i saw a little mini fist  pump from pragananda and we have a  result this night fork winning the black  queen ends in van forest  resignation i guess it's applause  to pregnant